[Music]
and that's so nice news that's so nice
nice Oh death so but if I shout out to
the editor who shoutouts to those guys
and it was good job
a guy describes the time his car got
broken into and Ozzy Osbourne stepped in
to replace his CDs what that's nice it's
very nice of him I bet you he doesn't
remember yeah some cracked out [ __ ] yeah
so this dude named Josh from Canada he
was me yeah his car was stolen as he was
making a delivery a food delivery and he
just got all of his CD collection stolen
and so he posted about it on Facebook
and then it got picked up by blogs and
like a rock music magazine and that's
where one of the musicians which is our
Osborne's longtime guitarist named Zakk
Wylde his son saw that and then
contacted Josh and asked for his address
like a sentence and stuff and then
that's when he got a package in the next
week and there were a [ __ ] ton of merch
on things like collectible things and
and even Ozzy himself sent stuff like a
photo that said like to Josh so this is
that's so cool that's [ __ ] rad dude
okay so that's what you do make it so
that all my Eminem CDs get stolen and I
make a Facebook post and like a Twitter
and be like really sad maybe a crying
video or something and then Eminem will
somehow hear about it and he'll send me
a bunch of stuff maybe it'll come in
person I don't know I would say I would
send you a letter like why you still got
CD collectibles why you why do you have
collectibles in the car though you
should be framing those so if someone
broke into your enemy Eminem shrine if
you had your Eminem shrine like in your
in a bedroom just dedicate it to him who
says she doesn't it's not in my bedroom
it's in the litter
hey I have a brick from his childhood
home and it's they´ll nice
yeah they only oh you [ __ ] up his
house no he sold them he sold them and
it came with the sign card and the you
only sold 700 of them
and it has like a reason you bought a
brick I know what to get you for your
birthday no seeds go to Detroit housing
project so it helps the charity because
he's know about this yeah it's in front
of his desk and he still married you
yeah I put it all on the table
I even quoted Eminem in our wedding vows
what he knew he was getting into what
did you say yeah what was it it started
with like I promised this I promise that
I promise to never go back on that
promise in fact let's be honest that
last relapse CD was a and then I said I
promise I'll never quote Eminem and our
wedding vows ever again yeah you know if
you caught it you caught it and that's
what no that I'm quoting Eminem that's
when all this these family was like I
can't believe you married a black girl
they just were like that's so beautiful
because they didn't know what that was
no it was just poetry that's okay yeah
yeah I wish we would have been able to
hear those vowels live yeah well I wish
I heard your vows soo-ji oh I can't wait
til you have your first kid yours like
hush little baby up on the dude yes so
here's the rest of the stuff that you
got Ozzy dance hey swag swag swag he got
hooked up I would love jay-z to send me
some [ __ ] he was like after you know a
whole lifetime of success and all this I
cute they still take the time out to
accommodate one that's very nice of them
dude I want like jay-z to just like get
a napkin and put some chapstick on a
kiss that [ __ ] huh in the Senate to me
it would be like do you ever hear that
Eminem renegade you know a lot about
we're doing you know we know all the
words you know quiet here seems like I
like the Slim Shady LP but after that
yeah you didn't like the Marshall
Mathers LP I like the Marshall Mathers
obviously I say the first three Marshall
Mathers Slim Shady and Eminem show those
were like the best and then he got angry
and angry and just all angry no he got
to addicted to drugs and it just like
that way it went into like weird accent
[ __ ] like he just started d12 yeah that
one yeah around that time yeah that was
always a thing though so it was more
around the Encore time and then all the
fans including me were like what is this
this sucks
and then he's like no it does and it's
great and then on the next CD he was
like defending encore and then the next
CD he's like yeah sorry you guys were
right I'll never go back that's the one
you'd said the line that I did in my
vows where he goes ever so interesting
why Eminem have all the people I just
related to him weirdly that's her
generation though it was my well yeah
and then also he was just like I'm and
like a lose like an outsider kid like I
heard you loser loser look like covered
up is it he was a loser yeah he was and
he talks about it and like he talks
about how he's glad he went he was the
weird one cuz now he owns his weird and
like that's how I feel
cuz I just felt about weird al' yankovic
talk a little relate to him that's not
my generation well I guess it kind of is
music he was every generation I don't
know I'm the Lynwood then would ya
Lynwood California
I wouldn't know who which like celeb I
want to pop you want a piece of Tupac
notebook I like I like Tupac I like him
I think I'd be super happy with a ton of
like Tarantino swag
like from his movies or what everybody
signed something at the pretty time yeah
I don't know thank you give me little
relics from his movies like if he gave
me Jamie Foxx's blue suit
he sent from Django he sent that over if
he sent me like a Nazi suit from
inglorious basterds
I want something for like movie mmmm
like prop stuff yeah just like random I
want a jazz CD or so our jazz little
record thing from The Cosby Show I love
The Cosby Show
I watched that many episodes I he was
like my my The Cosby Show was like
everything to me like it was B is my
favorite sitcom hands down till this day
that's just so although even yeah it was
it was it was [ __ ] okay I do was
ahead of its time though I liked it a
lot oh I don't even remember that many
episodes meaning those boys showed up
black people like they're just a regular
family it just I had everything that I
liked like Bill Cosby in that show he
was [ __ ] hilarious especially how you
would talk to his kids it wasn't like
the typical sitcom stuff that you would
see and then on top of that his wife
Felicia Rashad dude she was so [ __ ]
dope on that show she was like the type
of woman that I wanted to like as a kid
I want to be with the girl like her you
know what I mean cuz she had her [ __ ]
together she was a lawyer
she became partner she [ __ ] did all
this [ __ ] you know I was like oh
anything I [ __ ] I don't go third I
like Bill Cosby
maybe not the rape stuff it's like
Michael Chen maybe not like Michael
Jackson allegations
[Applause]
50 new allegation it's confirmed hey
listen at the 32 month I was like
alright maybe he might have been Michael
Jackson is not even a pedophile he
there's no there's no there's no proof
there's no proof there's no proof of
Bill Carter oh my god I think we just
don't want to believe it because he's
such an icon and he was such a big part
of everyone's life that my thing is I'm
talking about Bill Cosby the TV show
character yeah you're talking about Bill
Cosby the rapist it's two different
things he's talking about Michael
Jackson the musician you know I'm
talking about Michael Jackson you gotta
follow the art not the artist you can be
a fan of art without being a fan of the
a hundred percent that show it was his
character that I really enjoyed in his
comedy everything else is outside life
I'm not supporting that [ __ ] I'm just
saying that Bill Cosby Show like it
helped me a lot it was my [ __ ] dude I
got it I still like Louie CK I Love Lucy
but I mean I like his art maybe not him
as a person but I like his comedy all
you ever did was like FaceTime [ __ ] or
whatever god no he did a lot he raped no
but he likes traffic girls and like
masturbated ahead of them yeah that's
like not hardcore rape that's still
pretty fun pretty sure it's bad for some
people 100 but he's you say basically
compared to real violent rape it's not
as bad as real violent rape yeah but he
failed to say that it's done for example
if I was a hardcore but you feel bad
he's not saying that it's not bad he's
just saying if you compare it to one
kidnap violent rape that's being
tortured in a freaking week we don't
need to prepare right right but that's
what his dos don'ts fools are calling
louis c.k like a long [ __ ] [ __ ] what
good is he is though here but that if
you leveled up and he actually a
hardcore rape someone then he wouldn't
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] anymore no he's a
pushing with [ __ ] [ __ ] regardless on
the rape skill he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] or
something
shreds in the car on the studio no it's
bad okay Louis CK's baddie [ __ ] up he
shouldn't be sexually assaulting people
that's tough the obvious how many state
the obvious you do need to say you do
people don't know why are you sad
you got to create a baseline for your
argument before you even go to the
[ __ ] okay bark once we're out a box of
tissues picture take a picture tyka
louis c.k i'm against what he did and
it's wrong but i'm just saying that it's
not that bad compared to some actual
hard she because i sometimes honestly i
think society we get caught up in first
world problems that we magnify beings a
lot that should be he got away with
doing that because it was such a like oh
whatever his but they're sweet but
they're treating like him jacking off to
a girl in his hotel room that he didn't
physically touch they treat that as if
it's nobody basically kidnapped her
because she wasn't a lot to leave she
she was trapped there and she doesn't
know if he's gonna harm her or not like
scary like a guy that you can't
he's [ __ ] fact what does that mean
you're you're talking as bart who's your
size and your mentality yeah you're not
talking as tip yeah you know just a girl
chief would just wiggle right through
the cracks it's terrifying
I feel like jokes
I like sleazy kid I think you you can't
use the word not that bad yeah when you
say not that bad it sounds like you're
permiss you're you're making it okay cuz
it's not that bad I see that the you
just have to be careful for the words
that you choose because it is basically
like like saying murders not that bad
because they're serial killers out there
but what you're trying to say really is
there there really are serial rapists
out there that are going around and and
Luisi case shouldn't be in the same
category as a person who's kidnapping
women
torturing them and [ __ ] them and then
that's how basically your argument is
being framed is that you wanna you don't
want him to be in the same circle as
these guys that are you know crazy
individuals that need severe amounts and
that people are reacting the same way to
work at it like this isn't Charles
Manson yeah this is just a guy with a
weird perverted fetish but it's still
wrong and I'm saying yeah everything
that he did as a person is wrong but I
think you could still appreciate the art
without liking the artist anymore
[Music]